you just wear big pants and just dump it
in there and get it back out yeah
[Music]
i'm michael che from that damn michael
jailer hbo max
please watch it and now i'm going to
read some questions from that damn
internet
if you could be homeless in any city
where would you choose
that's a pretty good question definitely
new york city because well
there's not a dry butt
in this town apparently no man it's got
to be new york city because there's this
no you guys start walking to like san
diego or florida or some [ __ ] i didn't
know using this video too
sorry
he's in my light no no definitely new
york city man there's a lot of places to
hide and i always feel like i feel like
you want to be in a city there's a lot
of places to hide there's a lot of
there's a lot of crevices and nooks and
crannies i know guys who allegedly made
like a hundred grand panhandling up
there like in the bronx my dad always
told me never trust the word of a
panhandler he might be bad at math
i made a zillion dollars
[Laughter]
can you still go to your barber
if he is very racist i don't know a
barber that's not a little racist
bombers are like the most strongly
opinionated [ __ ] on the face of
the earth and anybody with a strong
opinion has some choice words to say
about certain people from certain
regions
so i'm going to say yeah absolutely in
fact i encourage you please be racist
you know i understand this question
though cause this is a very white
question this question is this question
is kinda racist because you guys think
you're the only ones that can't be
racist
uh-uh you ever met a whole dominican man
no they don't like anybody no no no yeah
for sure please be racist
please can you use a gift card on a
first date yes i encourage it please use
a gift card on the first date first of
all i don't think dates should cost
money your first date should definitely
not cost money it should be a walk it
should be something boring it should be
where you get to know somebody because
that way you can know if you want to
spend the money and also what kind of
money to spend you take somebody that's
not used to a fancy restaurant to a
fancy restaurant now you've just set the
tone for the rest of your life i said
use a gift card
no this is something i know i know i
know more about dating than being
homeless to be honest with you
if you could put any franchise
restaurant in your house i don't even
have to finish reading a question white
castle or taco bell a white castle slash
taco bell and a popeyes
i like i like drinking and i like
pooping but
a clean white castle is like it's like
my great white whale i would love to do
movie dick again where i'm just sailing
the ocean looking for a clean white
castle that's not gonna tear my insides
apart because i love the food so much
and i hate paying for it i just wish the
girl was cleaner matter of fact we were
just in we were in minnesota uh doing
shows and we saw a white castle i lit up
like a [ __ ] christmas tree i was so
pumped because i was like these white
people got a good white castle
they did not it ruined
it was the burgers were hard right it
was it was awful chicken rings are dope
the milkshakes are dope white castle is
the bomb it's just filthy we used to do
this thing i think keenan used to do it
i think like we would get like a bunch
of white castles during either christmas
or finale week and i think i think
keenan used to buy them and you'd smell
it throughout the building with permeate
like it's the best i don't know what
they put in there i think fentanyl
i don't know what they put in it but it
[ __ ] works it's good it's good white
castle that's for sure all right would
you rather everyone be naked all the
time or clothed all the time
i'm gonna say clothed just for like
smells purposes i feel like you don't
want to know what a room smells like if
we was all butt ass naked yeah it would
be pretty rough and also you gotta that
means you gotta sit on [ __ ] that
somebody else sat on butt ass naked yeah
i'm showering
yeah but there's ways around can i like
lift
can i like dude like
you just wear big pants and just dump it
in there and get it back out yeah no for
sure if you could have any snl alum as a
drinking buddy for one night
who would it be
ooh that's a good one you know who would
be honestly
it'd be eddie murphy and here's why
cause eddie i don't know if you haven't
met him but he's very kind of like
reserved if you ever see him in
interviews he doesn't really give you
much you know he makes sure he he knows
how to be famous you know what i mean so
i imagine getting really really drunk
with eddie murphy he'd have the most
insane
hilarious stories it'd probably be
awesome i think eddie murphy is six
drinks away from being my best friend
come on let's do it ed
what is the one thing that someone can
say
that makes you immediately
hate them
i don't watch tv i just don't like
hearing that i don't care that you don't
i just don't like hearing you don't
watch tv because i feel like it's a brag
like you have something better to do
with your time i just know what i hate
man i'm like
i have very few
reactions and that's one of them i don't
like anybody telling me that they don't
watch tv [ __ ] you if you were murdered
who would be the most
likely suspect
damn i guess
this would be a weird place to say this
publicly
yeah i don't know like who how do you
even answer those like with the crips
like i don't know
who do you think is just going to kill
you i never really like thought of that
god i hope my exes wouldn't want to kill
me i got yeah i don't know i don't know
maybe one of kanye's goons or something
i have no idea i don't know who would
want to kill me i hope nobody wants to
kill me please don't kill me if you're
thinking about it don't
please don't kill me you have a choice
between a sum of money and world peace
how much money would it take for you to
give up world peace
50 bucks no uh
to give up world peace i'd have to have
enough money to do something
very peaceful and still be filthy rich
because let's be honest that's what we
want right we don't want to spend all of
our money
on world peace and we could just have
world peace i'd say it wouldn't be much
need for comedy yeah it'd be kind of
selfish to be laughing at the world
peace i say
give me elon musk though give me like i
could buy twitter
yeah i could buy twitter cash
yeah give me elon musk money and and
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] if if uh the
middle east doesn't get along
none of my problems
i can live wherever i want what the [ __ ]
i can live where there is peace but i do
think elon musk has enough money to have
like if you could just buy twitter that
way you could solve a lot more problems
you can be fine you know what i mean
come on elon do something man i
literally cannot believe we got michael
j to do answer the internet but if he'll
do it anybody can do it anything's
possible make sure you leave a comment
who you want to see next and make sure
you're subscribed with notifications on